معركه دون رابح مع خساره وزنه على الجهتين
هذا ما اظهرته سيناريوهات متعدده تحاكي
غزوه صينيا لتايوان الجزيره التي تتمتع
بحكم ذاتي وتطالب الصين باستعادتها بالقوه
اللازمه الامر 24 سيناري واجرهم مركز
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه والدوليه في واشنطن
استبعد جميعها خروج الصين منتصره من هكذا
حربه بل دفعها اثمانا هائله وبحسب
المحاكاه الحرب ستترك البحريه الصينيه في
حاله من الفوضى وتحطم جوهر قوتها البريه
والبحريه وستفقد الصين 255 طائره مقاتله
و138 سفينه كبيره وفقا تقرير
خسارتها تمتد لقواتها مع توقعاته بمقتل
حوالي 10,000 من جنودها واسرع عشرات
الالاف وفي خانه المدافعين عن تايوان تقف
كل الولايات المتحده واليابان البلدان
سيخسران عشرات السفن الحربيه ومئات
الطائرات المقاتله و خسائر بشريه بالالاف
فمعظم السيناريوهات تتوقع ان تفقد البحريه
الامريكيه حاملتي طائرات وما بين عشره الى
20 سفينه مقاتله كبيره فيما تقول التوقعات
ان نحو ثلاثه الاف ومئتا جنديا امريكيه
سيلقون مصرعهم خلال ثلاثه اسابيع من
القتال اي نحو نصف ما خسرته في عقدين من
القتال في العراق وافغانستان
اليابان ايضا خزائرها ليست بقليله وفق
المحاكاه اكثر من 100 طائره مقاتله و 26
سفينه حربيه حاله شلل ستعانيها البلدان
الثلاثه في حال حدوث الغزو واسع النطاق
للجزيره البالغ عدد سكانها 24 مليون نسمه
لكنه مستبعده وفقا خبراء
فرغ ما قيامها بعمليات توغل منتظمه في
المياه والمجال الجوي قرب طيوان الا ان
بكين لن تخاطر بهكذا مناوره معدومه
النتائج وتضر اقتصادها بشكل هائل